Eliot is dead to me our partnership is
over I told you to walk away from this I
don't trust him you should have listened
to me what we started is over this is my
revolution I came here to talk about our
options there's something inside me that
can't let go of what we started
hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
mr. robot season 3 episode 4 trailer
breakdown some cool stuff in this and
one of the things that stands out right
away is the fact that we see a lot of
the characters and the voice-over has
broken down between all of the main
characters so it looks like we're gonna
be seeing a lot of different stuff
happening in the upcoming episode there
is a simple synopsis out there and it
goes like this
Dom has a close call Eliot chases
himself with Darlene on the lookout the
complete voice-over is as I mentioned
split up between a lot of the major
players here starts out with Tyrell we
hear him say Elliot is dead to me our
partnership is over then Elliot says I
told you to walk away from this Darlene
has a sequence first she says I don't
trust you that goes into her saying you
should have listened to me and then she
says what we started is over so it does
make sense that those could all be one
conversation with Elliot say but the way
that is presented I didn't feel that way
when I first watched it so we'll have to
see when it comes out after that mr.
robot says this is my revolution I am
the architect Angela adds I came here to
talk about our options and then it
finishes up with Elliot saying and
there's something inside of me that
can't let go of what we started visually
nothing stands out to make this trailer
seem much different than any of the
other ones we usually see from mr. robot
a lot of quick cuts with some things
that you wouldn't notice if you didn't
slow it down
or watch it several times first thing we
see is the first thing we see is Tyrell
sitting behind a terminal he appears to
be reading or looking at something he
sort of gets a reaction there but
there's nothing that we can tell we're
hearing the voiceover as this goes on
and it's him saying that their
relationship is over which doesn't fit
with anything that we expect to happen
going forward after we just learned
about Tyrells unending dedication to
Elliott in the last episode my guess is
that this would be right after he shot
him obviously and therefore he thinks
that there's no way that it'll ever be
repaired it could be something else you
know I browsed the reddit thread earlier
whenever I was first looking for the
trailer to get a hold of it and
everything else and there's a lot of
talk about Tyrell and his feelings for
Elliott that seems to be something
that's coming to the forefront now
especially since we saw how that all
went down in the arcade there's a lot of
discussion about who he actually gets
along better with the Elliott
personality or the mr. robot personnel
and there's actually a bit to think
about there I don't want to go down the
rabbit hole in the trailer breakdown
necessarily because I think we'll get
more to go off of when this episode
actually drops but yeah there is quite a
bit to think about prior to him finding
out from Angela what's actually going on
so it's not that big of a deal I mean
yeah he should have been confused about
what was happening in the switching of
personalities initially but as far as we
know I mean he was gone
Elliott was locked up they came back
together he shot Elliott and as
Elliott's recovering before he wakes
back up before they are reintroduced
Angela explains to him what happened why
he's like that why he tried to stop them
after he told him to shoot him if he
tried to stop him so I'm not sure if
there's anything that's really deep
there but it's an interesting part of
the voiceover that's for sure I mean it
stands out as like what the hell is he
talking about we just watched an entire
episode where we saw how devoted he
actually is the next short sequence is
Elliott we see him from below he sort of
looking around suspiciously and throwing
something in a trash can we've seen him
throw things in trash cans before it was
usually the hardware his disk drives
that he destroyed and then he went out
into his neighborhood and sort of
sneekly dump them in random places
there could be more going on here the
synopsis said that Elliot chases himself
and this is the scene that stood out to
me the most as being related to that
line but I couldn't tell you more about
what's going on it's just he looks
paranoid he's dumping something and at
the same time the voice-over is saying I
told you to walk away from this my guy
says that has to do with Darlene that
hits him and Darlene talking but it
could apply to basically anyone we may
see a resurgence in the storyline of him
wanting to separate Angela from the
situation he didn't want her involved in
the past and I could see that coming up
again although as viewers we know that
she's way more involved than he
understands at least at last we knew
there's a quick shot of Elliot on the
security cam that the last episode
before the flashback ended with this is
the FBI DOM and her new partner watching
as he enters the building that the safe
house is in this is really just sort of
a this is really just the sort of
reshoring the same thing there's nothing
new that I noticed in this when looking
at it closer we have another shot of Dom
sitting behind the computer she's
thinking she knows that she has to
figure out something if Eliot's in the
building it looks to be the same as the
end of that episode as far as I can tell
we see her partner there as well with a
look on his face that is what's going on
why is this guy here after that we see
Darlene sipping a beverage at a bar
looks to be an adult beverage from what
I can tell this part is for the
voiceover where she says I don't trust
you is she talking to mr. robot since we
found out that she also can tell the
difference or she's just talking to
regular old Elliot or if she talking to
the FBI I mean this shot is in
bar talking to DOM but I'm not sure the
voiceover is directly related to that
interaction and we do see Dom in the
next frame where she's there and yeah
all we can tell for sure is that Darlene
and Dom are meeting at the bar there is
a shot of Elliot and Darlene on the
street he's got his work shirt on his
trunk Club special there and nothing
really seems out of place from what I
can tell from looking at this you know
zoomed in and all that kind of stuff
there is someone walking down the street
but it could just be anybody in New York
City the whole background is blurred out
for the most part so you you know it
there's nothing it looks like they're
focused on each other and they're having
a conversation and that's what this is
all about could be related to the
voiceover of course and we see Darlene
returning the photo to his place on
Elliot's mantel there when mr. robot
confronted her for compromising them in
the previous episode we saw that she was
looking at that photo this appears to be
a day in day time like at a different
time it wasn't in the middle of the
night like the last time but there's not
much else to glean from this she may
have taken the photo away before and she
may be returning it if you remember in
season 1 when Elliot looked at this
photo at that point it was just him and
his mother that was the period of time
when he didn't remember that Darlene was
his sister or didn't know who mr. robot
was when we see the photo now all four
of the family members are there that may
tie him with what I was mentioning in my
recap and review of episode 3 where I
said you know that part of time where
Elliot didn't remember Darlene may be a
lot more important we know he had stress
going on we know he was doing morphine
those are all reasons that could play
into his delicate situation and that
might be why he didn't remember them but
there could have been something else
before that that we still don't know
about and of course we know for sure
that when it's revealed to him that
Darlene's his sister she says did you
forget again so this could be something
that's been a long repeating cycle
throughout his lifetime
there's a little part of mr. robot here
where we see that things are distorted
around him it's not the same effect
exactly that we saw last season when
they were sort of glitching back and
forth but it's almost like you know it
looks like reality is sort of blurring
in and out I don't know how to better
describe it but this could be a battle
for control of who's talking to whoever
this is involving right here I mean that
makes the most sense to me but also you
know involve some sort of deterioration
and Eliot but either way it seems like
mr. robot is not a hundred percent in
control and this short little sequence
here shot of Tyrell from the back
sitting at a laptop nothing stands out
as being important in this shot it cuts
to him and Irving and we see a little
bit more of why that's going to be
important like see the last episode is
gonna be important we learned Tyrell is
definitely kind of off his rocker I mean
he is insane that's what mr. robot likes
about him he's the right kind of crazy
you know I mean so herbing has proved
himself so far to be a very level-headed
manipulative character and to me it
looks like the the groundwork he laid
and that hideout is gonna put him in the
situation where he'll be able to guide
where Tyrell actually goes and what you
know what Tyrell actually prioritizes
there was some tension obviously because
he was stuck in the house but
considering what happened after he left
there Irving is definitely in the
driver's seat when it comes to him I
mean Tyrell can't go out and function in
society he has to stay hidden so yeah we
see what that's all about when we see
this bit here
it's another shot of Irving sitting on a
couch and I imagine it's the same
conversation I can't really say that
there's a reason to think it's not that
conversation then when mr. robots
voice-over is going you know we hear him
saying that he's the architect that it's
his operation we have a shot of him
strangling Tyrell against the wall it
looks like the same wall that Irving
sitting front of it's the same place
this could be the thing that happens
that relates to why Tyrell said their
part
her ship was over but it's really a shot
about mr. robot trying to maintain
control
trying to move stage to forward and for
whatever reason given Tyrell a little
choked reminder that he's the boss it's
a quick glimpse of a peephole where we
see mr. robot through there it's a nice
looking little visual thing but no other
details to go off of there at all
over at Corp we see Elliott in his
cubicle the way the shot is set up it
looks almost like he's doing something
that he doesn't want Angela to see you
know he looks a little bit startled and
like he's trying to kind of cover up
whatever he was doing there we see her
dressed in her white suit looking like I
don't know I mean I mentioned this
before Angela makes the transition into
white and we see her mostly in white
after a period of time whereas we always
see Elliot was the black hoodie and it
was you know there's a there's an
obvious comparison to Elliot's methods
being black hat and hers being white hat
but we've come a long way since season
one and where their motivations were so
it just reminded me when I saw this it's
like what is Angela really doing you
know I mean we're finding more and more
out about it she's mostly hell-bent on
revenge but white rose has some kind of
serious control over her so her
voiceover kind of stands out and saying
I came here to talk about our options
because frankly we don't know who she's
talking to when she says that the
trailer cuts to Darlene moving through
the tent city kind of thing that we saw
in earlier trailers we see Angela
deliver her lines not a hundred percent
where she's at it cuts back to a scene
that we've seen from previous trailers
of Darlene and Elliot at his apartment
and the trailers this was tied with the
voiceover which I'm going to paraphrase
in that they were trying to figure out a
way to stop stage two no additional
context is added here see Darlene in
that same getup entering the train
station with a nice little equine
billboard there in the back
ground and then we get a wider view of
what I think is the same thing that we
saw was Angela earlier and I say I think
because it doesn't a hundred percent
look the same behind her in what you can
see in this shot here we're back with
Tyrell this is where we saw him this is
the same area where we saw him talking
to herbing and so does she come to talk
to Tyrell about what their options were
if so in this scene he's slamming his
hands against the table in a fit of
anger so I don't know what that will
turn out to be but she's definitely
talking to Tyrell here another shot of
Elliot and Darlene together which makes
me kind of excited I kind of like
whenever they have scenes together
honestly they're entering his apartment
again and then we get this teaser thing
that we had seen quite a bit before
season 3 started of the agents coming in
guns drawn and a man with a F Society
mask putting his hands up behind his
head I still haven't heard any
conclusively compelling ideas about who
this is with this mask on the hair looks
like it's you know kind of combed back
like longer and sort of greased back it
could just be a random the teaser it was
in was sort of like you know you can't
catch us all or something if I to
paraphrase because I don't remember
exactly but it gave you the hint I think
that at least what I took away from it
was it gave you the hint that there was
a lot of people out there unconnected
type people that were doing things in
the name of F Society and it ends with
that like I said before the last part of
the voiceover was Elliott saying there's
something inside me that can't let go of
what we started that sounds like mr.
robot to me it could be something else
it could be part of Elliott himself but
I think that I've rambled on about this
long enough at this point so I will end
the video and tell you I want to hear
what you guys think in the comments make
sure you like the video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already you can follow me on
Twitter that's where I'm most out
but I also keep an Instagram and
Facebook account that I you know try to
keep posts going on whenever new videos
happen I but say this looks faster this
episode looks fast like it looks like a
lot of things are gonna happen but you
can't really tell from the trailer I
mean they're all fast so interesting to
me that all the people are talking and
the voiceover it's a good sign when we
see so many different characters
involved I think there will be a lot of
movement so that's it for now thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon